[Music]
there are a few things in life it's
thrilling as a life formula one race the
speed and roar of the engine sends
adrenaline pumping through your veins
but this isn't just mere entertainment
racing at the highest level test
engineers and drivers in ways that
normal production carriers do not and
forces them to think of clever and
innovative ways to improve performance
these technologies have on multiple
occasions found their way into our
everyday lives there are countless
examples of this happening since the
birth of competitive racing the first
reliable steel disc brakes was produced
for the Jaguar c-type in 1953 the
exposed disc brakes allows the brake to
shed the heat generated in braking much
more effectively than the drum brake and
allows stopping distances to decrease
this technology helped the Jaguar c-type
to reduce wear on the brake and reduce
braking distances allowing it to take
three of the top four places in the 1953
24-hour LeMans and has been saved
thousands of lives in the real world due
to their superior braking and
reliability over the course of the
24-hour race many of their competitors
had to drop out of the race because of
their brakes disintegrating the improved
brakes also meant the drivers could
break much later into a turn and thus
post much quicker laps racing
technologies are always a few steps
ahead of production carriers but these
technologies generally trickle down over
time has cost reduced carbon fiber is
probably going to be the next great
innovation and carry manufacturing all
air phone carriers use carbon reinforced
compsat brake discs which save weight
and are capable of operating at higher
temperatures than steel discs but you
will rarely see such high-end materials
in normal everyday carries the material
was first used in the monocoque of f1
carriers in 1981 when McLaren unveiled
the mp4 one the material had been used
for small parts previously but some
engineers doubted its ability to
withstand a crash that all changed when
John Watson crashed his McLaren at the
Monza Grand Prix and came away uninjured
John himself doubts he would have been
so lucky if he'd been driving in a
traditional aluminium frame after that
day the other racing teams were playing
catch-up and now every f1 current uses
material carbon fiber has slowly found
its way from high-end racing carriers to
production cars thanks to care
manufacturers like BMW who have made
huge investments in manufacturing carbon
fiber production has typically been
incredibly expensive due to the vast
energy required but BMW invested 300
million into a hydro powered carbon
fiber manufacturing plant in Moses Lake
Washington with the aim to produce 9,000
tons of the material per year
exclusively for their cars
this increase in production quantity
reduced the prices enough to make it
viable for production carrots like the
BMW i3 and i8 which have an all carbon
fiber reinforced plastic frame carbon
fiber is becoming more and more common
and we can expect to see it gradually
replacing metal parents in our transport
because it reduces weight and thus
reduces energy consumption while also
being incredibly strong it has even
found its way into our passenger planes
with the Boeing 787 Dreamliner and the
Airbus a350 xwb being primarily made
from comps and materials but more on
that in my next video these examples go
on and on but today we're going to focus
on the leaps in our understanding of
automotive aerodynamics as a result of
competitive racing some of the most
talented aerodynamicists in the world
work for modern-day f1 teams and the
lesson they learned through racing has
helped improve the efficiency of our
cars and mentally allowing them to cut
through the air effortlessly dry faster
and use less fuel but it wasn't always
this way
in the early days of competitive racing
there wasn't really any distinction
between race cars and street cars
the only discernible difference was the
lunatics that were driving them the
distance between the left and right
wheels were narrow and the centre of
gravity of the carrots are high making
batter is incredibly unstable and turns
susceptible to rollovers early sports
raising carrots were typically
lightweight front engine vehicles and
their designers understood the basic
concept of drag the engines at their
disposal were relatively no powered and
inefficient and so to counteract as they
made their cars as round and streamlined
as possible to reduce the effects of
drag drag is defined by this equation
where a row which is a Greek letter that
looks like a pea represents the density
of the fluid
object is moving through V is the
velocity C is the coefficient of drug
which is a property defined by the shape
of the object and a is a cross sectional
area of the object you can see from this
equation that the drag increases
dramatically as the speed of the car
increases because the velocity is
squared that is why to gain even a tiny
bit of speed at the higher levels of
racing huge amounts of additional
horsepower are required this is why
these early designers focus so much on
lowering the drugs for their low
horsepower vehicles the coefficient of
drag for a circle is just 0.47 while a
square is one point zero five so by
rounding a shape we can reduce the drag
by more than half and if we decrease the
cross sectional area by half we can
reduce the drag by half again so it's
clear why the shape affects the
performance of the car so much this
equation is useful for understanding how
drag works but the designers were not
getting a full picture of what was
happening to the air around their cars
because they had essentially just
designed Aero foils that were capable of
producing lift at best this reduced the
cars ability to transfer power from the
tires to the ground at worst it made the
car begin to lift off the ground and
crash one of the first people to realize
and attempt to correct this problem with
a young Swiss engineer and driver called
Michael May he recognized the potential
of using an aerofoil to create negative
lift and thus push the carry towards the
ground thereby improving traction grip
and handling of his car he modified his
Porsche type 550 by mounting this huge
inverted wing over the cockpit the wing
proved so successful that it beat all
other Porsches in its first race in 1956
at the Nurburgring 1000 kilometer race
this drew criticism from Porsches
factory team and they pressured the race
organisers to ban the wing on the
grounds of the block the view of the
drivers behind him
this incident stalled the development of
downforce generation but the idea was
too good to go unnoticed for too long in
1963 Jim Hall mounted an adjustable wing
onto his LeMans winning chaparral 2e his
controllable wing meant that it could be
made horizontal to reduce drag on long
straight sections of the track and
lowered when entering turns at this
point the idea could not be ignored any
longer and manufacturers began to design
entire carriers around this con
that rather than just going for the most
aerodynamic shape possible there is no
better example of this than the
evolution of Porsche in the late 60s for
should made a name for itself as a joint
killer with its sleek low drag roadsters
that we're managing to beat much more
powerful Ferraris and Maseratis well as
the company grew Porsche decided to
design a new high horsepower racing
engine and build an innovative body
around it and thus the iconic Porsche
911 was born its birth was not without
its share of difficulties early on it
was plagued with aerodynamic instability
this new form of high power and low drag
was a new concept to Porsche and it took
them some time to perfect it but they
gradually repro filed the bodywork and
the nine one seven began to dominate
races in the early seventies this
progression had a boiling point with the
accidental discovery of ground effect
with the Lotus type 78 during the
development of the type 78 the head
engineer Peter Royce and his team were
experimenting with prototypes of a new
design for aerofoil side pods in the
Imperial College London wind tunnel over
the course of the day the rudimentary
prototype wings began to sag towards the
ground of the wind tunnel and to the
amazement of the team there was a huge
increase in downforce initially they
didn't understand what was causing the
increase but soon discovered that by
adding cardboard skirts to the side pods
there was being forced and trapped
beneath the car and as we discussed in
previous videos when air is forced
through constriction it experiences an
increase in speed and a decrease in
pressure this is called a venturi effect
they later developed these brochures
that sealed the air under the car which
were later replaced with rubber skirts
this low-pressure air relative to the
high-pressure air flowing over the car
caused the huge increase in downforce
with only a marginal increase in drug
making the car stick to the road in
corners and reach incredible speeds on
the streets this was the holy grail of
aerodynamic discovery and all Formula
one cars since have followed this design
principle the Lotus type 78 set the
standard for what we see today the
successor to the type 78 the type 79 was
so dominant that team bug problem had to
think of even better ways of achieving
that ground of tank phenomena the bravo
bt 46 it's probably one of the most
controversial carriers to have ever hit
an f1 track teams were struggling to
keep up with the
type 79 and Brabham's team led by Gordon
Murray we're trying to figure out ways
of beating it Gordon Murray was reading
through the rule books when he noticed a
loophole the rules stated that carries
with moveable devices that were
primarily used for aerodynamic
advantages were not allowed but he
realized that if he could make an
argument for a new device being used
primarily for cooling then they could
use a fan that sucked air from the
bottom of the car and run it through the
engine the energy from the system would
primarily be used to cool the engine but
it had the added bonus of sucking the
carrot onto the road
the bravo bt 46 from the Lotus pipe 79
faced off in the 1978 swedish grand prix
and despite complaints from colin
chapman the founder of lotus the fan car
still ran Mario Andretti driving the
Lotus took an early lead but the Bravo
driven by Niki Lauda was gradually
gaining and eventually overtook and
riding on the outside Niki Lauda and the
brown bt 46 went on to win the race by
34 seconds but this would be the fan
carrots first and final competitive race
other drivers complained that the car
was firing rocks and dust at the back
and despite the carribean was in the
regulation the other teams pressured the
FIA to outlaw the car problem we're told
they could run the car for the rest of
the season but instead decided to
withdraw leaving the door open for Lotus
to win the 1978 Formula One season the
following year loaded slipped fourth
place as other teams caught up for
ground effect technology
I think this exemplifies why I enjoy
racing for me it's less about the
drivers and more about the engineers
behind them competing to create the best
vehicle possible within the rules today
engineers have a huge amount of tools at
their disposal to rapidly prototype new
car bodies I mentioned that the type 78
was tested in a winter and that testing
helped towards the discovery of ground
effects but prototypes are
time-consuming to make and winter homes
aren't always available to everyone one
of the biggest developments in f1 and
engineering in general the past two
decades has been the advancement of
computer-aided engineering with this
method we can simply generate a huge
variety of models and test all of them
in a short space of time to quickly
figure out which design is best the
animations you are seen on screen right
now are actual engineering simulations
that actor
depicts the airflow over an f1 car I've
teamed up with sim scale an online based
engineering simulation software to bring
you more of these animations and future
with this kind of power in an engineered
hands so our growth can happen so much
quicker and that's looking because the
regulations and f1 are constantly
changing and challenging the design team
behind the car
[Music]
thanks for watching I'd like to give a
quick thank you to market eno for the
fantastic footage of modern-day f1
carries and as usual thank you to all my
patreon supporters I've teamed up with
dftba to produce some awesome t-shirts
featuring the real engineering
gear-tooth logo they are currently
available for pre-order if you follow
this link which will also be in the
description I'm also adding it as a
$20.00 reward on my patreon last week
was the anniversary of my first official
upload and it's been an incredible year
of growth so thank you to all my
subscribers for making 2016 an
incredible year I expect 2017 to be even
more amazing